hey guys it's Thursday late-night
shopping day in Australia where we're
getting sure than real things to
celebrate but in any case well let's do
so with some gaming news I'm gonna do
what's embrace race and that's where the
celebration first up a new trailer for
Marvel vs. Capcom Infinite has been
released and it shows off some new
characters in action for the first time
dubbed the full story trailer the video
is jam-packed with all your Marvel and
Capcom favorites as we already knew the
primary villain is Ultron Sigma but it
looks as if the infighting kicks off as
a result of disagreements over how to
deal with them the previously confirmed
characters ghostwriter and Dormammu was
showing off for the first time and
spider-man rocks up in a black outfit at
one point that's pretty good
another happy news channle the odd
looking face appears to have been fixed
up after Capcom pledged to do so the
game will appear at Gamescom next week
to showcase its newest characters Ghost
Rider Dormammu firebrand and Jetta you
can check out the full 30 fighter roster
in our gallery on GameSpot last week we
told you about the leaked details of the
ps4 5.0 update and today Sony have come
out to officially reveal what's coming
there's no huge features in this one and
sorry for those of you who are hoping
for the ability to change your PSN name
yes we see you in the comments that's
not included in this update but what is
here should improve the system overall
ps4 pro earners with a worthy internet
connection will now be able to stream
1080p 60fps and for those of you with
the psvr
you'll now be able to see new messages
and comments while broadcasting virtual
5 and 7.1 surround sound has also been
added to PS via the friends list is
being updated with the ability to set up
separate lists of friends say for those
of you who have a destiny fire team or
overwatch competition group the quick
menu will now show the progress of
downloads your Spotify playlists just a
PSA here don't broadcast your music over
voice chatting games it's really really
dumb and new party invites for the
parents out there parental controls are
being overhauled with the master
sub-account system being replaced by
family manager you can now designate an
account as a parent or guardian adult or
child with the parent guardian and adult
accounts being able to restrict child
accounts in their use of online features
PS store spending and communication with
other players among other things
has said that anyone in North America
who wants to set up an adult account
will be charged 50 cents to verify that
they're an adult clearly they haven't
checked my bank account the firmware is
going out to beta testers today so if
you're lucky enough to be a part of it
and have a few codes left over be sure
to share the love let us know what you
think about the new features and what
you want to see come in the next major
ps4 firmware release and down below in
the comments those of you out there
eager to pre-order the Xbox one X may
not have to wait much longer that's
right rumors are abounds that pre-orders
will open this weekend according to a
tweet from the Verge's Tom Warren
pre-orders will open this Sunday August
20th following Microsoft's Gamescom
press conference
Microsoft is yet to confirm the details
but they did release this tweet which
aligns with the rumor timing will be
bringing you everything from games come
so make sure you're subscribed if you
keen on checking out Microsoft's
conference for yourself you can shoot in
from 12:00 p.m. Pt this Sunday the Xbox
one x will cost 500 bucks in the US four
hundred and forty nine pounds in the UK
and six hundred and $49 Eidos in
Australia when it launches worldwide on
November 7 that is everything very happy
today do remember that tomorrow we've
got our top 5 stories of the whole week
if you need to get caught up and but
until then have a great evening did you
like my little song having a
conversation
you